White House Press Secretary Robert Gibbs...
...called to wake President Obama early Thursday with the unexpected news.
I think it's safe to say he was very surprised.
Less than a year after taking office,...
...Mr. Obama is joining an elite group of recognized peacemakers...
...that includes Nelson Mandela, the Dalai Lama and Martin Luther King Jr.
Mr. Obama's tone was one of humility.
To be honest, I do not feel that I deserve to be in the company...
...of so many of the transformative figures who have been honored by this prize.
Men and women who've inspired me,...
...and inspired the entire world through their courageous pursuit of peace.
Global reaction was swift and varied.
UN Secretary-General Ban Ki-moon described the peace prize as "great news".
President Obama embodies the new spirit of dialog and engagement...
...on the world's biggest problems,...
...climate change, nuclear disarmament, and a wide range of peace and security challenges.
Several Nobel Laureates were in agreement, including South Africa's Desmond Tutu.
It's an award that anticipates an even greater contribution...
...towards making our world a safer place for all.
Former U.S. President Jimmy Carter described the Obama selection as...
...a bold statement of international support for his vision...
...and commitment to peace and harmony in international relations.